but you've been doing like it's cool
because i you were doing some i saw you
do some comedy night [ __ ] right yeah
demo i do my own comedy show so
um i'm trying to touch money in every
[ __ ] area you're also hilarious like
you're like a special but it's like
you're my kind of like bro the first
time we met and you rapped on on my show
and yeah yeah you andrei was there yeah
yeah bro i was like
i love
that level of like just your bars just
was like so [ __ ]
crazy i was like me and this guy are the
same kind of guy
absolutely but it's it's a dif it's like
if somebody gives me a microphone it's
like yo go in front of that crowd and be
[ __ ] hilarious i probably won't be
but if i'm just normal we on the street
we're just joking
i feel like you can do crowd work yeah i
just have to put in the work i know i
mean like because you know there's like
comedians who have like a 10 minute set
oh yeah people that just [ __ ] with the
crowd but then there's like guys who are
really good like andrew scholes is like
yeah he's an amazing regular comedian
but he's also great at just if there's a
couple in the front row that look crazy
nah i didn't know i went to a show the
infamous he gave me tickets i got i'm
cool with him now i was like oh you went
on this show right where you wanna no i
did like i saw him talking about it yeah
he talked about it on the show i also
linked up with him i did uh he did a
video to promote his concerts that were
going on so after i did that he gave me
the tickets to radio city and i actually
watched this show the guy's [ __ ]
hilarious and he was and i know that's
when i started seeing how he was [ __ ]
with the crowd and then the other day i
was with russell peters like i saw that
i love here right yeah a lot of these
comedians like [ __ ] with me and wrestle
peter's a [ __ ] hip-hop head i didn't
know that hardcore russell peter's a
[ __ ] real one i [ __ ] with that he was
dj in it yeah yeah he was using hey
before he was a comedian he told like we
but he invited me he's like yo you went
to l.a come [ __ ] with me i went to his
house just thinking i was going to say
what up bro me my whole crew stayed
there probably the whole night till like
from like four afternoon to like two in
the morning it's amazing and and just
had a great time dwayne martin from
above the rim
well well chillin it's like surreal
these are all people you know above the
rim you grow up a girl watching that um
soundtrack
we talked about that yeah we talked
about that the great that soundtracks
what other soul in the hole
was that the one where
his brother died and he was like i
didn't even see the movie i still
noticed is it that one
soul in the hole wasn't dwayne martin in
another basketball movie where he's a
basketball player
he spoke about that he said oh he's in
white men can't jump he's a white man
can't jump okay yeah
there was a wayans brother in a movie
where one of the two guys died and his
br it wasn't dwayne martin then do you
know what your movie i'm talking about
like it was like two guys were on a team
they might have been brothers or they
were best friends or something and one
of the two guys died and then the rest
of the season like the guy's ghost is
like helping him play like crazy but
it's like a comedian yeah it's like a
comedy i don't remember it wasn't a good
movie
but you know